-Well rested and ready to go.
It's so good to see everybody.
I am in a good mood.
Last Saturday was
the Creative Arts Emmys
in Los Angeles, California,
where "Corrections"
was nominated.
You guys want to see an Emmy?
Do you?
Me too.
[ Laughter ]
Can give you the name of
a couple of late night hosts
who have plenty at their house.
[ Laughter ]
Me and Shoemaker went, and...
Suffice it to say,
Mikey the Shoe don't like L.A.
[ Laughter ]
He lands in a bad mood.
Complains the whole time.
Says stuff like,
"If I wanted green juice,
I'll drink it from
a jar of Claussens."
[ Laughter ]
So, it's like...
It starts bad
and it just gets worse
because we...
Donna from Wardrobe...
We decided sort of
last minute to go,
and we were off all month,
and our tuxes were here.
And so we wrote
Donna from Wardrobe,
who very kindly
put together a box,
a garment box,
and sent it to us at our hotel.
So anyway, I'm getting ready
for the Emmys,
and Mikey the Shoe calls up
and he goes,
"I think she sent
two of your shirts."
And he goes...
How'd you say it?
"Mine don't fit so good"?
[ Laughter ]
So he comes up to my room,
and I'm like...
Based on the fit,
I don't think it was
one of my shirts.
It was maybe
one of Frisbee's shirts.
It was not even close,
and he's going like,
"Maybe I'll wear it backwards
like a smock."
I'm like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
So he goes, "I got one."
"Don't worry, I got one
in my room, but it's blue."
So, we go to the Emmys
and Mikey the Shoe
is in a tuxedo
with just a blue shirt,
which he keeps saying
is "Bronx formal."
[ Laughter ]
"If it's good enough
for Danny Aiello..."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway.
Look, I know they voted ahead
of time and it had been decided
that we had not won
when we showed up.
But I think if they'd seen
Mikey the Shoe
and his blue shirt,
if we were the winner,
they would have just
crossed it off.
[ Laughter ]
Eminem was a big winner
that night.
The Super Bowl halftime show,
deservedly --
was fantastic --
won an Emmy.
And we mentioned that
in a monologue this week
that with the Emmy
that Eminem won,
he now only needs a Tony
for the EGOT.
We joked that you should keep
an eye out for him
in "Dear Evan Hansen."
Now, more than one
Broadway aficionado amongst you
pointed out that show
is no longer Tony-eligible.
So, in order for Eminem
to win a Tony for that show,
he would either have to be
in a revival
or -- bear with me --
a new show called
"Dear Evan, Stan's Son."
[ Laughter ]
Here's the idea.
It's an alternate take
on the Stan saga where Stan dies
but his girlfriend lives
and then has the baby.
And she names the baby Evan.
And it's a story about Eminem
befriending young Evan
because he feels bad
that he never wrote back
his now-dead dad.
I don't have time
to write this.
That's an idea
for whoever wants it.
I am so behind the eight ball
in "Cicada, Cicada" right now.
It's going way too slowly,
and I'm racing against the clock
because if the Mets win
the World Series this year,
I'm [bleep] 'cause
that is my whole third act.
[ Laughter ]
And if you're surprised
that it's a three-act play,
it's actually four.
[ Laughter ]
But the fourth act
is just a Q&A.
With pre-vetted questions.
We also mentioned a news story
about images of the Titanic.
The highest resolution
photos ever
were taken
of the Titanic wreckage.
And we said,
but now the bad news --
no survivors.
And you guys, a bunch you said
there were, of course,
survivors from the Titanic.
We knew that.
Our joke was based on the fact
that you'd go down there now
and find a survivor.
Which brings up an interesting
ethical question.
If you did find one,
let's say a 110-year-old person
who somehow, I don't know,
there's an air pocket
in the... galley?
Boat kitchen.
And, or maybe the saltwater
has helped preserve them,
but they're, you know,
a robust, happy,
I don't know,
110-year-old person.
Do you bring them up?
Or at this point,
would it just be too jarring?
I don't know.
Speaking of the ocean...
Oh, son of a gun, I...
We'll save that one.
[ Laughter ]
Shoemaker, next week
during "Corrections,"
just yell out
"speaking of the ocean."
[ Laughter ]
I quoted a Bob Dylan lyric
in our last "Corrections"
as his famous song,
"It's Not Me, Lady."
A bunch of you,
the ones who recognize jokes
the best,
said the line is actually,
"It ain't me, babe."
[ Under breath ]
Come away from my window...
Leave at your own chosen speed,
I'm not the one you want, babe,
I'm not the one you need...
You say you're looking
for someone
who's never weak
and always strong,
support you and protect you
whether you're right or wrong,
someone to open each
and every door...
[ Louder] It's not me, lady.
No, I was right.
That, of course, is a great song
off the classic album
"Bob Dylan,
But This Time From the Left."
[ Laughter ]
I said Rudy married
his second cousin,
but then I referenced the
daughter of his first cousin.
The daughter of his first cousin
would be his first cousin
once removed.
A lot of you were very,
very passionate
about that correction in a way
that makes me think it's
something you've angrily yelled
at a skeptical
justice of the peace.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm not saying it's right!
I'm saying it's legal!"
[ Laughter ]
Second cousins is when
your parents are first cousins.
Second cousin once removed
is when you marry your second
cousin and then divorce them.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, we make a lot of fun
of Rudy
for the old cousin mix-up.
But you know who married
his first cousin?
Albert Einstein.
This was courtesy of you guys.
Albert Einstein's second wife
was his first cousin.
Their mothers were sisters
and their fathers were cousins,
which means they were both first
and second cousins.
They never had kids.
Thank God!
[ Laughter ]
Don't need to be a physicist
to know
that would have been a bad idea.
We had a month off, a little bit
too much time to have off.
I got to be honest, very happy
to be back this week.
I think we're all very happy.
It was nice
to catch up on stuff.
Shows, movies, books.
There was that, um,
"The Lord of the Rings:
The Rings of Power."
Super succinct title.
Classic Tolkien style.
[ Laughter ]
"The Lord of the Rings:
The Rings of Power."
I haven't seen it.
I guess it's on Amazon,
but I couldn't watch it,
because I'm a 48-year-old man.
[ Laughter ]
Mugs!
So, last time we were here,
I said, the mugs were
available online.
And guys, you backed me up.
The mugs were a hit.
The mugs, on the first day,
sold out,
I think both due
to your enthusiasm
and maybe the doubtful nature
of those in the NBC Store
who ordered
the first set of mugs.
But this is true. It really did.
All jokes aside, it went great.
These are...It was...
It is the best-selling mug
on the NBC.com store ever.
That's just a...
That's a true thing.
The worst-selling is, uh...
...Chicago Mug.
[ Laughter ]
And I guess they don't even sell
the "To Catch a Predator" mug.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's kind of...
This part, I like.
It says, "Why don't you have
a seat over there?"
[ Laughter ]
And this...
But I'm worried because I guess
this one's available soon,
with Keith Morrison
drinking a mug with a picture
of Keith Morrison
drinking a mug.
[ Laughter ]
Guys...
These are are the data
on the mugs.
We're really excited.
It's sold 1,369 units.
Now, you might be thinking
"Oh, is a unit just one mug?"
You're right. Yes.
So, that's 1,369 mugs.
But that does not count
the physical store.
The physical store has sold 59,
so I should have
put that one first.
That's not a big number.
[ Laughter ]
Only 17 complaints
about the mug.
Some of you have posted photos
on Twitter of a --
Very kind of you.
You've opened up your mugs
and they're just shattered.
It does seem like
they're in a million pieces.
I don't know.
I don't know how that happened.
I do, we do want
to replace those mugs.
So just, if you could just send
a photo of that,
we do obviously need to know
it's you, so just send
a photo of that mug
with your driver's license
and your Social Security number
and, uh...
[ Laughter ]
Some of us asked are the mugs
dishwasher and microwave safe.
They are.
Thank you for asking.
We did a lot of testing
to make sure.
That was the --
that was the hold-up.
That's why it took a year,
is we wanted to make sure.
The whole, the first,
the beta test,
a lot of them were either dish--
they were one or the other,
and you could wash it
in the dishwasher
and everything was fine,
but if you put it
in the microwave,
just loss of life.
So we lost some good people,
a lot of good people,
but you can put it wherever
you want,
except a box
surrounded by bubble wrap.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, so, I mentioned
the Emmys, and...
I...
Look, we didn't win, but had we,
I did take it seriously.
I never want to be one of those
people who you win an award
and doesn't know
what he's going to say.
And I had some things to say
about the jackal in my speech.
And I mentioned that to one
of our writers, Seth Reiss,
who said, "You should read
that speech
in the next 'Corrections.'"
Which is funny because
that's what I was going to do,
and now I can't!
[ Laughter ]
Because now if I do,
it's also his idea.
[ Laughter ]
And next time I see him,
he'll be like,
"Ehh? Pretty good!"
This isn't for you.
[ Laughter ]
Get your hands off it.
This is mine.
You don't see me
trying to jump on to...
What has he...?
[ Laughter ]
"Actathlon"?
2017's "Actathlon"?
Now, in Reiss' defense,
I want to be sincere
for a moment.
He has been very busy.
He wrote a major motion picture.
It's got a trailer
and everything.
The trailer looks fantastic.
It's called "The Menu."
Ralph Fiennes, Anya Taylor-Joy,
Nicholas Hoult,
Hong Chau, Janet McTeer.
Trailer's fantastic.
It is premiering
this weekend at TIFF,
the Toronto International
Film Festival.
And we are so genuinely
so proud of him.
He's a great writer,
and it never stops being cool
when people who work here go on
and succeed somewhere else.
I should note, he co-wrote it
with Will Tracy,
who I haven't met,
but who I assume
has the patience of Job.
[ Laughter ]
Will writes for "Succession"
and used to write
for "Last Week Tonight,"
so head on over to his place
if you want to see
one of those Emmys.
[ Laughter ]
Reiss is very excited
and he said...
It's cool. He left.
He went down. He was on set.
He said he got to be really
good friends with the cast.
Although I have my doubts,
'cause he keeps saying
"Ralph" "Fee-en-ness."
[ Laughter ]
So in the end, Reiss did give me
an idea for "Corrections,"
just wasn't the one he wanted.
[ Laughs ]
But here's to the premiere,
the TIFF premiere
of "The Menu."
We're so excited to see it.
Here's to being back
with everyone who watches this.
Cheers to everyone
who's got their jackal mug.
And let's have
a wonderful fall together.
You will see me next week.